así que parece que tenemos algunos gatos
enojados en nuestras manos mía
[Música]
sí sin duda se ven enojados y lo que
vamos a hacer es pensar en cómo podemos
separar estos gatos enojados porque lo
único peor que un gato enojado son 12
gatos enojados que quieren apoderarse
del mundo entonces en lo que vamos a
pensar es si podemos dividir estos 12
gatos enojados en grupos iguales y solo
por el bien de este vídeo
digamos que queremos dividirlo en tres
grupos iguales cómo podemos hacer eso
bien veamos si puedo hacerlo este será
uno de los grupos por aquí tal vez este
sea otro de los grupos por acá tal vez
este sea otro de los grupos pero son
estos grupos iguales veamos el grupo de
arriba tiene cuatro gatos el siguiente
tiene tres y el otro tiene cinco así que
no no son iguales entonces no funcionan
necesitamos no sólo tres grupos sino
tres grupos iguales vamos a ver si
podemos hacer algo diferente se me
ocurre que podría atrapar estos primeros
cuatro gatos en un grupo después atrapar
los siguientes cuatro en otro grupo y
creo que esta vez va a funcionar
por último los siguientes cuatro están
en otro grupo y como acabo de decirlo
todos estos grupos tienen exactamente
cuatro gatos en ellos lo que es más
manejable y funciona
acabamos de dividir estos 12 gatos
en tres grupos iguales
y cuántos gatos en cada uno de estos
grupos iguales bueno podemos ver
claramente que hay cuatro gatos en cada
uno de esos grupos y cuál es la forma de
ver a la división en este ejemplo es que
empezamos con 12 y lo dividimos en tres
grupos iguales en tres grupos iguales y
terminamos con cuatro gatos por grupo
con cuatro gatos por grupo ahora bien
qué pasaría si quisiéramos interpretarlo
en una manera ligeramente diferente
traigamos otros dos gatos enojados lo
cual es muy peligroso pero lo haremos
por el bien del aprendizaje así que
hagámoslo
[Música]
así que tenemos más gatos enojados y
ahora imagina otra vez 12 entre 3 2
entre 3 pero esta vez no pensaremos en 3
como grupos iguales pensaremos 12
dividido en grupos de 3 bueno cada uno
de los grupos iguales tendrá 3 gatos en
ellos y esto nos dirá cuántos grupos
iguales somos capaces de hacer bien
hagámoslo vamos a crear grupos de 3 aquí
tengo un grupo de tres gatos enojados
por acá tengo otro grupo de tres gatos
enojados este es otro grupo de tres
gatos enojados y por último este es un
grupo de tres gatos enojados entonces
cuántos grupos de tres gatos enojados
tenemos
bueno tenemos 1 2 3 4 grupos iguales
así que si quiero dividir 12 gatos en
grupos de 3
terminamos con 4 grupos iguales 4 grupos
iguales y aquí lo tienes hay dos formas
distintas en las que podemos imaginar la
división y la misma expresión de la
división exacta de 12 entre 3 podemos
ver la primero como 12 dividido en tres
grupos iguales y la respuesta será
cuántas cosas hay por grupo o pensar en
12 dividido en grupos de 3 y eso nos
dará como resultado 4 grupos iguales